hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
among the various intellectual virtues
that is habits of mind you might say
then are being discussed in nikka mcKane
ethics books we find the one that is
translated in variety ways as art or
craft skill this corresponds to many
disciplines and the greek term for it is
technic this is indeed the word that we
get technology from which Aristotle by
the way is it was one of the first
people to use not so much in terms of
artifact but in terms of the people who
are creating certain artifacts the
backstory of that is that he calls
writers of manuals technolo boy in his
our rhetoric and we can come back to
that point towards the end and talk
about how that fits in here so one of
the key differentiating factors for this
is that it has to do with making or
production in greek places and this is
the word by the way that we get poet
from because poetry is one form of
police is one form of making but there's
many other kinds
making as well and Arizona wants to
distinguish this in a technical sense
from action or doing praxis you know the
differentiation that's taking place is
primarily on this basis what Aristotle
here is calling praxis are the things
that are done for the sake of that
activity they they might be productive
of something else but they have their
value in doing that very activity
whereas poetic production or or making
is something whose good lies outside of
the process of making it's the thing
that's made or the condition or whatever
it is that we're bringing as Aircel says
bringing into existence causing to move
from not being to being which could
include changing the states of things
now you might say and this is a very
important point that there's some
slippage between these that for instance
we might be engaged in certain kinds of
action because we want to produce some
sort of effect within ourselves
I think air some will be willing to
grant that there are also people who
engage in you know handicrafts on a
hobby basis because they they enjoy that
they're not very interested in the
things that they're producing they're
interested in the activity itself and
Aristotle would probably be willing to
say that considered in that life they're
actually engaged in action but they're
engage in action through engaging in
craft or skill and this will determine
the quality of these to the products
that they yeah we're going to want to
say it in some metaphysical terms the
truth because each of these intellectual
virtues including tech name is a way of
attaining truth well it would truth be
in this case it would be that the
product conforms to say the ideal that
the person has in their mind or the
purposes of the product aerosol doesn't
go into a discussion about that here in
this this section but there's nothing
that would preclude us from from reading
that yet so it involves the practical
sphere which is the realm of things that
can be different than they are and
indeed we're going to see that this
plays an important role so it's not
dealing with the same subject matters
that the sciences are for example it's
not to say that the climatic production
couldn't use what it is that the
sciences teach them so for example if
you're engaged in doing pottery you can
do it you know the way that the ancient
Greeks did but you're probably not going
to get quite so good results if you do
don't take into account what chemists
can tell us about you know all the
different kinds of clay and their
different properties
similarly glazing right like lazing is
really a matter of chemicals and
applying heat processes so you know the
same think if you looked at entry
different ways the the science can tell
you a lot about the properties of things
but it can't really tell you how to do
the craft itself that's something that
is within the practical sphere
inter-cell defines it and indeed defines
not only art or craft per se as a
generic thing but also defines specific
arts or crafts yeah as a rational habit
concerned with production rational means
metal logu so there is some thinking
involved there or at least some
reasoning across as a practical
reasoning process I want to produce this
here's what's required in order to
produce that in order to make it happen
well therefore I must do this to lead to
this it's also as he calls it hexxus it
is a camp it is a lasting disposition
that has been established in the person
this makes perfect sense when you think
about what is involved in any sort of
art or craft think about musicianship
for example if you've ever played an
instrument other than the kazoo or the
triangle you know that there's quite a
lot of work
involved in in progressing in acquiring
that kind of skill that's involved which
the product of which would be say a
musical performance or her me or you
know the enjoyments of the viewers and
listeners I suppose cabins have to be
developed over time cameras also do
involve some sort of principles they're
not just a matter of blind habit there
is some sort of rationality involved
some of other things that Aristotle
tells us about this that are
particularly interesting and determinate
--iv of this is that in craft the maker
is the efficient clause for the thing
that is being made the official cause
does not lie within the thing but rather
lies within the activity and the mindset
of the maker who is the one who is able
to actually perform it so this allows us
to to make some important metaphysical
differentiations here you know you
probably doesn't think they're gonna do
that I'm talking about arts and crafts
right it doesn't deal with things that
are brought into existence that come
into existence or that exists by a
necessity so you know we have to qualify
this a bit because you know you might
say well you know the Potter and in
firing the pot is making use of the
property of the properties of physical
materials and those are from necessity
yes but it's not like clay pots are
aren't popping up and random all over
the place well not at random by a
necessity all over the place being
formed and fire nor does the artist deal
with something that is by nature so you
know you might say well does that mean
that farming is not a productive
activity then because the farmer plants
the seed right and the seed does sprout
and grow and do all of its its stuff
according to principles within the thing
and Aristotle would say well two fields
occur by nature
you know think about the corn plant for
example or for your Europeans I think
they call it maize but here we call it
corn that is a genetically modified
product in you know the extreme and now
by scientists but by all sorts of other
people yes who kept reading it the right
way and I've actually made it into
something that we now recognize today so
if you look at the original plant that's
derived from not a lot of kernels there
so it can be dealing with things that
are natural but insofar as they're being
transformed and put into a different
context we're talking about something
that is the object of a craft or skill
you don't say that crafter still deals
with the same objects is chance that
doesn't mean that it performs it what it
does in a haphazard way as a matter of
fact it's sort of the opposite of chance
chance is just randomness or things just
happening to be the way they are with
skill there is intentionality there is
desire being directed towards certain
ends there is the production of a
product that might not be standardized
but certainly bears the marks of the
makers determinations not just chance
activities but it's dealing with the
same kinds of objects as chance you know
music you can strum a heart or a guitar
and you can make some sounds if you do
it long enough you might actually make
some things that sound pretty decent but
it's not going to happen all that often
the goal of craft or Tecna is to make it
happen more often and to make it happen
reliably when the person wants to do it
as a matter of fact Arizona actually
says I don't have the Sun for it but he
says at one point that when a crafts
person deliberately makes a mistake
that's not that because they're choosing
to do that and perhaps they're doing it
for some sort of effect like a customer
has been a terrible person so they're
going to give them a bath sad
right if they do it unintentionally
that's more of a problem because that
means that they don't really possess
their their skill or craft they don't
really understand why they made the
mistake that they did so sometimes being
able to make mistakes is actually
assigned ones one spark or craft not the
same thing by the way aerosol says with
you know science because it's not
actually science if Commission's
occurring the aerosol not the same way
with prudence if you make a mistake in
matters of prudence that's that's on
here that's bad examples he uses the
example of house building or equal
domain in this and that he says is a
rational habit concerned with production
if you think about it the making of
shelter is using natural products but
it's not using that in the same way that
nature does you know take the average
house and things are quite different
than they would be in nature even if
you're just digging a burrow then you're
saying well I'm doing like a bad well
human beings aren't like badgers and so
digging a burrow and making a house in
there is some sort of activity of craft
rhetoric another example you can put
words together in with different
audiences and different ways and you'll
produce different effects runner he
actually makes a study of that I
mentioned at the beginning that the
first reference to technology as far as
we know is the tech to low boy the
people who are writing rhetoric
textbooks Aristotle actually faults them
for not being very good at their skill
and leaving out too much they focused
primarily on the emotions on sir like
push this button you'll get this effect
push this button you'll get this effect
from the audience and they don't take
into account the importance not only of
pathos or emotion but also logos or
rational structure or argument and
ethics or character as well as other
things and so he writes an art technique
of rhetoric to be something that
that's better than that and this brings
us really the last point how do we in
fact learn arts crafts or skills there
is on the one side practice which is
required to establish a habit but we're
talking about a mental habit so it's
going to be informed by some reasoning
some principles and it involves a
reasoning process this is why it's
possible to critique performance you
know something that is that has been
brought out by technique by by craft by
skill we can say that that did not
achieve what what the intended aim was
you didn't produce the kind of product
where the product is good in this
respect but not so good in in that
respect so Allah is covered by this very
important indeed for human wine
irreplaceable intellectual virtue which
which spreads out through a whole number
of different individual arts and crafts
and skills